[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler j'ai ce
thème pierrât docteur en communication
bonsoir j'ai stand pierrât communication
politique même à votre dernière tribune
est paru dans entrepreneurs alexis
poulain éditorialistes qu'on connaît
bien ici évidemment est avec nous
également merci alexis enfin denis
jacquet entrepreneur vous est aussi
l'auteur de cet ouvrage le début de la
peur la faim d'une démocratie sortie le
26 avril dernier aux éditions eyrolles
bonsoir à vous et merci d'être avec nous
emmanuel macron accueilli donc sous les
sifflets le président contact des
marseillais la cité phocéenne qui est on
le sait le théâtre régulier de
règlements de comptes sanglants il y à
des messages alexis poulain derrière ce
déplacement et on oublie en plus le
professeur raoul qui fait beaucoup
parler de lui des petits messages
subliminaux basse et une visite kaka
thuram ont l'impression du roi qui sort
de versa et qui vient rendre visite un
peu là où ça va mal en disant je vais
être le sauveur de cette ville en vous
promettant monts et merveilles avec eux
le chèque bien entendu le carnet de
chèques emmanuel macron est en campagne
ce serait ridicule de ne pas le voir on
a eu manuel valls qu'il y avait un grand
plan ghetto inquiète elle a juste avant
l'élection de 2010 est également donc un
an avant les élections généralement on à
la politique car des tchèques qui arrive
est donc aussi un message c'est bien
celui là la mise en scène du corps du
président ce n'est pas à lui de faire ça
d'un côté on avait françois hollande un
présent qui ne doit pas dire ça
aujourd'hui on a amené le maquereau un
président qui ne devrait pas faire ça
c'est le rôle des régions de fer les
transports et l'éducation mais il arrive
en disant je vais m'occuper de cette
ville il ya une condescendance chez
emmanuel macron il ya un mépris de tous
les corps intermédiaires y compris du
parlement et c'est le cas là avec les
élus locaux qui la traitaient d'ailleurs
en disant il faudrait qu'ils
s'organisent un peu c'est pas à moi de
tout faire en gros mais on lui demande
rien en réalité à part 2 jouer son rôle
de président de la république et
d'arrêter d'être un candidat permanent
jean luc mélenchon qui est effectivement
critiqué ce côté monarchique du
président de la république et qui disait
on a bien à un emmanuel macron campagne
électorale
sous-entendu que sous-entendant qu'avant
lui il y avait eu nicolas sarkozy
également sur le terrain marseille
manuel valls clairement marseille c'est
pas un hasard c'était le passage obligé
bien sûr que c'est pas un hasard comme
l'a récemment montré le film de gimenez
avec gilles lellouche bac nord sur les
difficultés qu'il peut y avoir dans la
police a à marseille bon marseille c'est
un concentré de colère et emmanuel
macron et est allé là bas parce qu'il
laboure sur les termes les thèmes de la
droite ils essayent de siphonner d'aider
des voix est bon bien évidemment vous
avez raison de le rappeler il ya eu
sarkozy avec guéant qui sont déplacés
jean marc ayrault manuel valls donc
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron essaye d y
aller mais ce que vous appelez
condescendance et mépris moi je dirais
que non c'est c'est sûrement un esprit
supérieur à une rapidité prodigieuse est
bon il a du mal à s'adapter sa
communication et pas toujours très
heureuses mais c'est pas c'est pas de la
comté sont nantes c'est plus bon une
rapidité à comprendre et du mal à
s'adapter
aux hautes avoir de l'empathie y avoir
de l'humain plus qu'autre chose mais bon
évidemment qu'il est qui commence déjà à
rentrer en campagne est bon il essaye de
présenter les thèmes de l'adversaire et
puis on cueille angulaire en tout cas à
huit mois de la présidentielle un
emmanuel macron va devoir défendre
clairement son son quinquennat et on va
le voir les français ne sont pas très
satisfaits de son action c'est mieux que
ses prédécesseurs mais c'est pas
vraiment brillant regarder ce sondage il
faut paru aujourd'hui qui va s'afficher
puisqu'il s'est affiché tout à l'heure
j'ai bon espoir qu'il revienne sur
l'écran super 1 marseille donc le
président qui va présenter son plan
parle de mesures économiques le site
renfort de magistrats les thèmes
prioritaires en regarder c'est
intéressant aussi pour les mois qui
viennent plébiscité par les français
d'après les résultats toujours de ce
sondage ifop paru le 30 août voici les
thèmes prioritaires clairement denis
jacquet emmanuel macron veut montrer aux
français qu'il est capable d'agir dans
les domaines régaliens
en fait si vous regardez bien ce qui
s'est passé pendant la crise due qu'au
guidon à nier totalement l'existence des
mères on alliés totalement l'existence
des régions en les considérant comme
suffisamment incompétent pour qu'on leur
confie surtout pas les n'est que la
gestion de la crise avec un succès
énorme comme on le sait tous et donc
aujourd'hui mais finalement on continue
à surfer là dessus en disant l'état est
tout puissant l'état et le retour l'état
c'est moi et je me déplace effectivement
jeu j'apprécie toujours les
interventions de d'alexis avec qui on se
retrouve sans le savoir soleil sur le
plateau je trouve néanmoins c'est un
côté effectivement alors je ne sais pas
si le mot est condescendant mais en tout
cas on voit bien que macron c'est très
bien habitué aux habits régalien un
trait présidentialiste que la
constitution de la vème république a mis
en place qu'il est très à l'aise dedans
en tout cas qu'il croit être à l'aise
dedans et qu'effectivement marseille
c'est un espèce de de croiser très
intéressant parce qu'en même temps c'est
là où mélenchon justement qui qu'est ce
qui est très rare n'a pas parlé tout à
l'heure puisqu'il devait s'exprimer soit
voulu se présenter à la fois d'une ville
qui était issu d'un berceau aussi
d'immigration dont on sait qu'ils votent
plutôt plutôt à gauche alors que macron
est en train de virer à droite donc ça
lui permet de continuer à labourer un
petit peu et puis c'est le message est
effectivement l étape tout l'état
providence l'état qui a effectivement
s'est endettée prodigieusement c'est en
cassant la machine par sa gestion du
corps locaux vides et en tentant de la
réparer ou de l'amortir de l'autre côté
en sortant le carnet de chèques donc
voilà on a un maquereau en campagne on a
plus aucun doute là dessus on est parti
là et en gros c'est le parisien qui
vient expliquer à marseille ce que c'est
que la vie donc moi je trouve ça
forcément un peu supportable c'est pas
non plus une première ainsi pas le
premier président à rentrer en campagne
neuf mois avant et se déplace en
province mais après dites petites
incartades polynésie et puis un dea
d'octobre pour certains ministres on est
maintenant à marseille donc on voit là
ses déplacements n'ont plus rien en tout
cas ne sont plus le fruit du hasard
c'est une certitude sauf que alexiens le
maire de marseille après vient faire un
chèque ne suffira pas
clairement que peut faire emmanuel
macron dans cette ville là il vient de
réaffirmer sa fermeté et sa
détermination quant au trafic de drogue
mais enfin c'est un combat qui va être
difficile de nos pays ont demandé 900
forces de police supplémentaires il
donnera droit à 300 forces de police
supplémentaires et bien sûr les
opérations de communication de gérald
darmanin la veille de la visite des
médailles seront donc on va en parler il
y aura sans doute d'autres règlements de
compte ça va pas se régler en une
semaine dans ce problème du trafic à
marseille que la sécurité ça a toujours
été un des points faibles des monnaies
de mâcon est clairement ça va être un
des thèmes majeurs de la campagne comme
d'habitude la sécurité revient souvent
quand on a une campagne présidentielle
donc il va être obligé de montrer des
résultats marseille serait évidemment
une façon de le faire mais encore une
fois le président de la république n'a
pas les les commandes là dessus il
arrive il se met en scène il met les
projecteurs tout le monde parle de lui
trois jours pour se mettre en scène
trois jours pour engranger des voix
également une campagne payée aux frais
du contribuable qui n'est pas prise
comme une campagne présidentielle alors
que en plus il va prendre la présidence
du conseil de l'union européenne en
janvier donc il aura en plus l'or là
encore il ya moyen de faire campagne
internationale et
donc tout ça brouille les cartes rend la
campagne difficile parce que on n'est
pas à armes égales en réalité et on voit
bien tous les ministres qui s'aligne
derrière emmanuel macron qui la parole
est en train de se réduire de se
rétrécir avec chaque ministre commençant
déjà à dire je suis derrière lui mais
pour ce qui est des élus locaux ils ne
sont pas dupes ils savent très bien
qu'ils sont utilisés alors il en profite
parce que on va pas dire non un chèque
quand ils arrivent mais évidemment il
faudrait être que conscient des suites à
donner je vois ghislaine pierrât voilà
secouer la tête la n est qu en écho avec
monsieur bon en fait c'est très simple
pour faire cette différence vous avez
raison de parler de résultat il doit
justement à la différence des autres qui
ont défilé et qui ont du thé sur cet
échec de la drogue du logement insalubre
bond de la crise identitaire de la crise
sanitaire explique et économique bon les
résultats il doit apporter en même temps
des garanties
et si ils amènent des garanties et si
partir du concret concret garantie
grogne égale résultats avec suivi donc
la différence elle est là il doit faire
sa résultats au cas par cas avec des
garanties et du concret et il n'y a pas
de raison de ne pas y arriver a
effectivement la drogue cc à la fois
marseille est une ville emblématique
deuxième ville de france très aimé des
français mais à la fois bon elle est
gangréné par cette drogue qui explose
donc
il faut pour former des policiers vous
l'avez dit il faut deux ans pour bien
formés et introduire les policiers pour
bien leur faire comprendre le tissu très
spécifique marseillais et ça va pas se
régler en un jour mais il faut quand
même donner un peu d'espoir et quand
même dire qu'on va essayer de d'arriver
cette fois ci a nourri de l'expérience
des autres nourrit des échecs des autres
a des résultats il ya du concret
immédiat du concret nous dit gsm chera
denis jacquet des garanties m'enfin
c'est très compliqué comme on le disait
il ya quand même ses prédécesseurs qui
ont tenté de jouer la même carte et avec
le succès qu'on connaît enfin plutôt
d'échec qu'on connaît
oui c'est clair mais moi ce qui
m'intrigue en fait dans ce déplacement
c'est sa durée serge j'imagine que pour
vous qui est observé l'actualité au
quotidien trois jours dans une même
ville c'est quasiment du jamais vu moi
je me souviens de d'être parti emmené
une délégation d'entrepreneurs en israël
avec françois hollande qu'elle fait le
plus long déplacement de
présidentielle à l'étranger jamais fait
il plaisanté en disant aux journalistes
broncher goût mais pas trop mais je vais
quand même rentrer en france soyez-en
certains dont on veut c'est ça c'est
celle c'était sa dérision mais là trois
jours à marseille j'allais dire pourquoi
est ce qu'ils pensent qu'en restant
trois jours
marquez où il a prévu tout un scénario
qu'on imagine pas et va se déployer une
série d'épisodes les marseillais leur
tour pendant trois jours mais j'arrive
pas à comprendre la durée c'est elle qui
a tellement de sujets pour cette rentrée
tellement de sujets importants ce qui
prouve bien qu'on est en campagne et pas
dans un sujet de la présidentielle du
quotidien on est vraiment en campagne
parce que qui peut passer en ce moment
en pleine crise du coc vide alors qu'at
on a encore un pas sanitaire alors que
l'élan de la reprise économique malgré
ce qu'on annonce est incertaine passé
trois jours dans une même ville c'est
qu'on est en train de passer un certain
nombre de messages je suis assez que de
savoir ce qui va se passer ces deux
prochains jours ce qu'il a prévu au
programme dans les épisodes à venir pour
qu'ils aient autant de messages à passer
aussi longtemps dans une seule ville
c'est moins ce qui m'intrigue vraiment
le plus aujourd'hui c'est vrai que trois
jours avec un sacré nombre de ministres
une petite dizaine ça veut dire quoi ça
alexis poulain que marseille regroupe
tous les sujets qui peuvent faire gagner
une présidentielle et que c'est
nécessaire de rattraper son retard dans
ce domaine oui je crois qu'il ya à la
fois arrivé là où jean luc mélenchon et
député donc se poser aussi face à
l'opposant et dans ce territoire il ya
la région paca qui a été compliqué sur
les rich animal mélenchon vous pensez je
pense oui parce qu'on voit sur la courbe
les les sondages augmenté lui la rentrée
politique avec l'ailé la france est
soumise et la réunion à valence donc on
voit bien que là aussi jean luc
mélenchon et sur l'offensive donc à voir
mais ce qu'on voit c'est que il utilise
marseille pour cette mise en scène avec
les ministres ça coûte cher je ne sais
pas combien de crs qui sont là pour
boucler la ville on l'a vu arriver sur
le vieux-port vide d'humains à part les
crs sous les quolibets et les huées
quand même des marseillais qui étaient
là donc il ya quelque chose de l'ordre
de la communication perpétuelle qui est
série temps dans cette façon de
gouverner également de 2,2 du roi
thaumaturge c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas
être le sauveur d'une ville en réalité
si les choses fonctionnaient alors il y
aurait peut-être eu au niveau local déjà
des moyens qui auraient été donnés sans
que le président à se déplacer avec son
barnum là on est dans la politique
circus c'est à dire que c'est vraiment
une mise en scène fait pour l'été les
faits pour les radios fait pour la
presse locale également pour dire
regardez comme je suis superbe comme je
suis formidable et élisez moi on repart
pour cinq ans je vous promets hier
encore plus d'argent et j'espère avoue
le docteur en communication on a vu ses
premières images des manuels micro à
marseille est étonnante un d'ailleurs en
plein coït je sais pas si vous les avez
vus avant de venir ici bien sûr
embrasser alors la foule qu'il ya eu des
quolibets et dénuée certes mais il ya eu
aussi voilà les marseillais qui venait
embrasser
emmanuel macron bon qui portait un
masque mais enfin cela en tout cas ces
marseillais n'avaient pas de marx et ça
fait quoi c'est quel impact de ces de
ces images assez étonnante alors en écho
avec vous deux bien évidemment que j'ai
trouvé border line les images avec les
gamins qui hurle les mails et les tout
ça et qui avait pas les masques et quoi
sa part c'est bon on est derniers
d'accord c'est border line ça sent
l'improvisation c'est mal organisé c'est
du grand n'importe quoi bon au milieu de
tout ça il ya quand même le congrès
vendredi sur la nature le congrès
mondial sur la nature il ya quand même
des des événements qui vont un peu
compensé avec ce côté bouillonnant
border line des sorties on sait pas
pourquoi ni comment c'est le café du
commerce
bon je suis pas sûr que ça plaise
énormément improvisé où c'est maîtrisé
oui oui oui bien sûr oui c'est un avis
oui c'est improvisé y'a bon bien sûr que
c'était censé être tructures et mais on
voit bien que bon ça a été très rapide
le choix des invités les lieux
l'organisation la scénarisation on voit
bien que ça a été extrêmement improvisé
donc bon ça souffle ça souvent été comme
ça c'est souvent été un peu cette marque
de fabrique au dernier moment paf on y
va ca c c'est préjudiciable
encore une fois
bon on a d'un côté une droite qui
empêtrée avec la halle à la primaire que
je condamne bien évidemment parce que
c'est un piège à noir il ya la gauche
qui est empêtré aussi parce que bon elle
voit pas bien son horizon avec qui y
aller et lui il a il a une différence il
est intelligent il est jeune il est
rapide il a un niveau nettement
supérieur ça se voit mais bon au niveau
communication c'est le petit caillou des
cailloux dans la chaussure chose moi je
crois qu'il est peut-être qu'il est
intelligent super super etc etc mais il
n'a pas de parti en réalité ce barnum à
marseille c'est pour cacher le fait
qu'ils aura pas d'université d'été de
l'ares aime parce que ce parti n'a pas
de militants est en train de s'évaporer
sous les yeux il n'y avait pas dit un
seul il est seul et refaire campagne
donc voilà on est d'accord bon il
n'empêche que bon ils ont quand même eu
des résultats je suis pas là pour faire
l'avocat je suis juste là pour essayer
de 10 voir clair mais bon il ya quand
même bon les 100 milliards la gestion du
coc vide c'était quand même pas ça la
raison 80 milliards c'est là la réforme
de la sncf qui s est bon il ya quand
même il ya quand même des résultats à
son actif bon si c'était facile ça sort
et le métier de président ce n'est pas
facile et la france est quand même un
gouvernable mais bon un pays extrêmement
souhaitant regarder les gens le pass and
it here et là il n'y a pas eu il ya des
gens qui manifestent un contre cette
mesure mais quand même 12 avril à
français avait stoppé les dialogues des
pinpins qui sont à la télé et qui disent
n'importe quoi sur un surnom je veux pas
me faire vacciner
non je suis tenace rôle
passagers vers l'avant
c'est du n'importe quoi à quoi bien sûr
qu'il faut se faire vacciner évidemment
on est on est pas sur un débat ronde
avec ça ou provoquent sommet mais voilà
toutes les opinions en tout quatre sont
sont bonnes à prendre
denis jacquet le mot de la fin bon 62 %
quand même de mécontents qui
n'approuvent pas l'action de d'emmanuel
macron vous pensé justement pour pour
conclure que ce type voilà de sortie ça
sera plutôt à l'avantagé des manuels
macron parce qu'on a vu que lors de la
première campagne ça lui a plutôt réussi
à ce type vver souvient ton sein chez le
face à face avec marine le pen dans
cette usine
voilà il avait plutôt réussi avec succès
ce genre de sorties en tout cas la
première campagne présidentielle
oui mais effectivement alexis de 10 et
un petit peu entre les lignes tout à
l'heure c'est un parti qui n'a pas
d'existence turc en gros le jour où
emmanuel patron quitte elysées il n'y a
plus de l hérault m donc à moins d'un
miracle donc et on l'a vu aux
européennes et puis on l'a vu aux
régionales ils ont aucun ancrage ce qui
est assez logique en même temps pour un
parti aussi nos fins très difficile de
créer un un parti en france donc du coup
un média d'autres partis qui sont très
liés à la personnalité de leurs
dirigeants à mélenchon en est un autre
exemple le jour il est pas là je sais
pas ce qu'il reste des insoumis il
restera toujours la haine et une
certaine forme de deux des sociabilités
mais néanmoins je sais pas ce qu'il en
restera donc il a besoin d'aller au
contact il est plutôt pas mauvais au
contact donc il a besoin de se
débarrasser d'une image trop
parisianiste donc il va forcément aller
en région tout le temps et on l'a vu les
dom-tom maintenant l'air marseille qui
est une ville emblématique donc qu'il va
passer son temps dehors de paris puisque
son électorat principal à paris plutôt
jeune et déjà acquis donc non il faut
s'attendre à d'autres séquences cédric
s'y passe trois jours à chaque fois on
se demande effectivement quand est-ce
que le gouvernement va gouverner
merci en tout cas ça restera en suspens
cette question merci à tous les trois et
vos avis divergent denis jacquet
gillesklein observa et alex et poulain